hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I haven't
streamed in a while so yesterday or not
yesterday last week almost everyone in
my family was sick so I took Wednesday
Thursday and Friday off so first I was
taking care of sick people and then I
was sick and so I'm not a hundred
percent yet but I'm almost almost there
so sorry about not streaming today we're
gonna just pick up where we left off on
Tuesday yeah Tuesday was the last stream
so for me I'm just I'm just picking this
up so I haven't really done much I hope
to be able to get some work done from
home but I didn't really get that much
done I was just exhausted so hey
everyone see you on the live chat there
I'm gonna get started by starting up the
end Rock server and I'm gonna paste the
link to that in the live chat so oh I'll
try to remember to paste it again in a
few minutes for the people that maybe
are coming in later that I don't know if
you can if you come in late can you
still see everything in the live chat or
do you just see like the last few things
that happen I don't know let me know
I'll probably still post it again no
matter what just to be sure I do want to
ask you a question so I had you know
someone who watches the the live chat
has been asking some questions on
Twitter and I keep forgetting to ask you
all because I'm not sure what the answer
is but they're creating a like a online
shopping cart so this is like an
e-commerce site and they're using react
so they're having trouble with their
you know with getting things to show up
in the cart so I'm not I haven't seen
the code so I don't know everything
that's going on but if anyone has done
any e-commerce stuff with react and you
have any suggestions or you know any
maybe like packages or something that
would help with that please let me know
in the live chat or you know through
some other means comments or on Twitter
or something and I will forward that
information alone because I've never
done e-commerce with with react before
so I'm not really I don't really have
the experience to be able to give good
advice in that area but I would still
like to help if possible okay where we
left off last week and we were we
created a switch statement and we were
using sort so we were mapping through
our data and then we were using dot sort
to sort everything in different ways so
we didn't quite get that working so
there's a problem with somehow how I set
up the the sort the sorting functions so
I've started to look at the
documentation because we copy and pasted
from previous project where the sorting
works I think the problem is the data
that I'm getting in now is different
from the data I was getting in in the
other application so that's where we're
gonna start and trying to get this to
work and this is not going to be a
really long stream so I did I got a
question about how long will the stream
be normally the streams end up being
between like one and two hours
I'm gonna save like an hour and a half
is about average today I can only I
could probably stream for an hour and a
half today and and it would be ok but I
can't go longer than an hour and a half
because I have something at 12:45 so
there's actually
in office st. Patrick's Day parties the
st. Patrick's Day was on Saturday
obviously no one was working on Saturday
so the party is today which is why I'm
wearing green it doesn't look green on
the camera though but this is a green
sweater but anyway I want to go to that
party and I think there's going to be
really good food there which I'm excited
about so that's why the stream is not
going to be too long so I better stop
talking and get to coding let me switch
my screen here okay so here you can see
I was looking at the documentation here
and I noticed that when we're comparing
numbers this actually works and that's
really what we're doing let me start my
time with as well and I'm gonna paste
that and grogg link one more time for
those who are just joining us I think we
had about maybe 20 people join since the
last time I posted it so there's the
link you'll be able to see the site with
that link so you can see that's what
we're doing here we're just you know
taking a and B all right the values of a
and B and we're doing a minus B so the
difference being we're not we don't have
numbers and this is what I I wanted to
see these are numbers so they should
work where they should daily should be
numbers so I want to double check and
make sure like are we actually getting
numbers what like what are we getting
you know before I start changing these
around you know how we're doing this I
want to be sure of what Dana that we
have and I see there are some questions
in the live chat I'll answer all the
questions when I take a little break so
after about another 25 minutes I'm going
to take a little break and I'm going to
answer all the questions so please be
patient with me
and I'll try to get to all your
questions before I before I finish today
okay so let me first let's go to the the
output that we're getting from the
WordPress API hmm and my stream is
getting some weirdness let me plug in I
forgot to plug in my ethernet cord where
do that
alright I found it you have a like I
can't see the back of my Mac right now
so I'm just trying to feel around there
we go alright hopefully that will keep
the stream a little bit more stable it
shouldn't cut out while switching yeah
it's not cutting out okay cool and all
right so so far it looks a little bit
more stable at least on my end it wasn't
my work wasn't getting any warnings
about stream quality from YouTube but
from OBS it was showing me red and
meaning that my my internet speed was
not not good enough okay all right so
let's let's check out the data and I did
have hmm I wonder if I still have it
over here
no yeah here we go
oops wrong one there we go okay so
here's our date here's what we get from
date okay and it is a string so I'm
gonna copy that and let's go over let's
go over here
let's do dates parse and then we'll put
that string in and let's see what we get
okay so we do actually get a number
let's see
well this work I can't ever remember
with the sin taxes for this let's see no
shoot I mean this this does look like a
number so I think we're safe with that
okay so I think we are getting numbers
oh okay I get so Anthony's saying just
use type of want to go three oh okay did
I use the wrong whoops oh my god no
capital okay no Calvin or thank you all
right cool it is a number so just wanted
to check all right so we have numbers so
these dates should work and I say okay
so let's see what's happening with this
function so when you sort by we're
passing in the type which is the type
when does this get called alright here
we go so we're we're manually passing in
the type date oldest okay now we're
manually passing in that site so it
should
this should work let's see make sure I'm
not doing anything in here that would
mess it up all right we might be getting
more than a hundred posts let's see what
we were searching by make sure we're not
getting more than a hundred pose let's
all right so we're only getting fifty
three posts all right I remember going
through this the less I mean through
this process okay and we're logging out
here's our dates three five twenty
so this is showing the newest first
which is not what we want let's change
this and see if maybe we haven't
reversed made newest
[Music]
hey Harsha how's it going I'm glad this
time worked for you
biology will work ok not it's the same
order
who
hmm
okay hey everyone I see ladies in high
enough shoot
all right what's going on what am I
doing wrong
you look back it was my original sedate
oldest I date oldest forgiveness
it was my time soon
okay let me
I wonder
if these are even running let's see
let's let's see what can I do with this
can I put something else in here oops
okay
okay so that is should be running date
analyst whoa okay
it ran a lot of times because we're
mapping over it I take newest so it is
getting the type sort of data exists a
data that's a log sort data
so does sorted data actually just
Francois chief I use so what is data sir
okay so I wasn't trying to save anything
to a variable here I was just sort and
then I was mapping I don't know why I
said we were mapping and sorting we're
not mapping and sorting so I apologize
for saying that earlier let's see okay
so we need let me see what sort does we
have a variable here that stores the
elements of an array in place and
returns the array this source not
necessarily saying all the default
orders at Clooney's she could finish
okay we did check this before so if we
have an existing array and we run sort
on it it will change that array okay
that's we needed to know all right so
let's go whoa hey maybe this is the
problem maybe that should not have been
Const let's try that out
I hope that is really the the answer to
this okay
all right so new lists I don't really
know since that's new list first I guess
we could check
all right let's change this to oldest
do the work
no what's it boy hold on a second okay
so it's working briefly haha I don't
know if you'll see this
you could probably try it out on your
machines now if you have the N grout
link okay so when I hit enter it briefly
sorts everything correctly and then it
goes back to the normal way so why is it
doing that all right let's see what
we're doing
so this whereby the oldest okay great
let's see what we're logging here
alright so this is sort of the right way
this is sorted the right way since 1750
yeah this one's sorted the right way all
right so we're getting and the spots
where we're console logging we're
getting the data in the right order
let's see where all right so we have a
console log here so at this point that's
this weird
whoa oh forget my plus sign there we go
that was a lot of red all of a sudden
now I should've known that what happened
alright there may be a better way to do
that but this will work
okay so why so we can see our dates here
and we're getting I should move this up
so y'all can see everything so we're
getting the dates initially in order
from the oldest to the newest it looks
like yeah and then afterwards it's still
in that same order but what's displayed
here is not in that order all right let
me get a little the live chat and see
what you all think
okay
yeah okay I see so harsh it's saying use
moment Jess I'm not really doing
anything with the dates I just need
I just want eat numbers so I just need
to turn the date into a number and and
I'm doing that the problem I have now is
I need to sort them properly
all right so Joey sing the sorting will
will actually modify the array that's
act that's what I want right now so
that's that's the behavior that I want I
want the array to be modified
see
it's okay let's alright so the problem
now
I think our sorting is actually working
so things things are sorting differently
depending on the values we pass in so
just to double-check that
let's pass in what are we using right
now oldest let's go back to newest just
to see that there's definitely a
difference in the order the newest yep
there's a difference even this is wild
why are we getting the difference
all right why are we getting the
difference though even here and in the
same data so our console law bits here
should not be reordering right so at
this point we haven't even called this
sorting function
this dangerous
actually let's do this
all right we are getting some change
recession
we have the exact same date for some of
these
hey see you later oh
all right I'm gonna switch back to
oldest because we were seeing definitely
a different change okay so we're still
getting that switch I was afraid we had
something going on you know with what
this may be running before it was
supposed to but it doesn't look like
that was doing anything let's see see
michael says type isn't getting logged
yeah our type is getting log here so
when we're running these console logs
here it is actually see date oldest is
running
all right let me take a break because
the timer ran out and I'm gonna answer
some questions now and then we'll come
back to it and I think we can get in one
more Pomodoro session okay so I'm gonna
scroll up
Anthony asked if I was using WordPress
as the backend
I am so we are getting data from
WordPress I mean I I don't know if I
would call it the complete backend
there's more going on but WordPress is
our content management system so we're
using it just for that we're not using
any of the display portion of word for
us
mmm D she hub says how many time
completed this course I'm not sure what
you I'm not sure what you mean let me
know maybe if you could clarify yeah so
I'm just not exactly sure we're here
what you're asking
Thao asks if building what am i what am
i building University website yep
so building a new website for Franciscan
University Michael said early start
again yeah early start I have stuff
going on in the afternoon so how to get
it in early
Kishor says how to set how to do this
setup in windows / linux the git repo
and everything yeah you can it should
run Linux for sure it should run Windows
I think it runs on Windows does anybody
run this on their machine on Windows I
think it works but I haven't personally
tried it yeah but all you would need to
do is just clone clone the repo and to
your local machine and then do NPM
install or yarn if you use yarn and then
after all the packages are installed
then just do NPM run dev yeah I think
it's def there are instructions on this
repo as well so if you go to the
repository links in the description if
you go there and just view the readme it
will have instructions for how to get
this up and running all right Bhargav
says what are you doing which language
it's it's JavaScript and we're using
react which is a JavaScript library and
in particular we're trying to sort some
numbers
so also a switch app in which I'm Mac so
I'm on I I don't know my iMac is 20 I'll
just show you I'll show you the stats
for the spec so I guess it's really
small so it's uh retina 5k 27-inch late
2014 I got the intel core i7 and 32
gigabytes of ram and i'm using Visual
Studio code Dimitri asks how old am I
I am 32 years old all right cool Joey
confirms that it does work on Windows
excellent Thank You Joey okay all right
and get through the questions just in
time so let me go we'll start another
Pomodoro session a few seconds early and
let's let's check quickly let me bring
this down a bit and let's get out of
node I'd like to run through this
briefly just to get an idea of the logic
of what's happening okay so all right so
initially our our data in state is it's
totally empty which is what we want
so when when we initiate the search so
this is called get search results and
pinnacles debounce search so it sets the
the value in state so we have that we
call debounce search which then calls
fetch search term and now word fetch
search term so now it just builds the
the search query and now we're calling
get JSON which we've imported from
another file which simply just uses the
fetch API so now we're passing it that
string that we've just created and then
we're getting the data and we're setting
that data into into state so now data
has all of the posts that have been
returned from the WordPress API then
we're console logging what that data is
then we're calling sort by and in this
case we're sorting by date oldest so now
let's go down to sort by so actually so
let's so we've had at this point we've
had one change in state so let's see
what would happen then so you've had a
change in state so we're gonna get a
rerender and now down here data dot
length will be greater than zero since
we had data so
then we're gonna map over it so we're
mapping over everything great hmm
we could move the sorting logic down
here I really don't want to but that's
how I did it in a previous project and I
know it worked there who wouldn't
actually be manipulating the data that's
in state instead we would just be
changing it about in terms of how we
display it let's let's let's move it
down to here that'll simplify things
we'll be able to get rid of some of the
stuff that we're doing right now and
it'll be a good candidate for a refactor
at some point but we can get rid of a
lot of this so we'll just comment some
some of this out for now so that we can
easily you refactor back to something
like this later so let's grab just this
part this sort and we're gonna copy that
and then for all of this goodness for
all of this we're just gonna comment
that out now we can do let's do our
sorting before we map obviously and so
now we're gonna get the data we're gonna
sort the data and let's know what all
right so instead of tight how do we do
this
you go back here okay we have the
sorting saved in a Redux tour but let's
save the sorting in State this time
if you do this oh yeah let's get rid of
these console us
it's wondering why I had typed so many
times in there okay great now we'll say
this state sort by and I think we
already have this in in state so we'll
just set it manually and then so after
this happens then it will then map over
everything okay let's give this a try we
do need to set sort by and we'll go
dates oldest okay refresh let's try that
out so we can see right now the newest
is shilling showing first now let's hit
enter you gotta be kidding me
I'm getting the phone call so let's say
you did hello hey how's it going
sure
mm-hmm yes
hmm
okay
yeah you probably maybe we can
conditionally have that load so when it
load on the editing pages yeah
okay all right let me see yeah let me
see what what form are you working on
right now anything in particular
okay
yeah yeah just make yeah make sure that
that I have access and I can see it and
I'll check it out and then I'll try the
like the conditional loading of the
styles and make sure it works but if it
works then I'll apply it to all the
other forms that we're using their
styles for all right yeah no problem
okay all right so that was one of my
colleagues in the IT department it seems
that a project that we worked on earlier
which was adding styles system
Salesforce forms gentleman think those
particular forms that he was talking
about I don't think I live stream that I
did live stream some other forms we were
working on but the problem is when you
go to load the editor page for those
forms the Styles are being applied and
they're messing up the interface so they
look fine to the normal user when they
go to fill out the form but when someone
an ite or somewhere else on campus tries
to go to the admin panel and edit
doesn't look good so I'm thinking like
you probably heard what if I just add
something to where you know if if
there's a certain string that we can
find in the URL that make the notes that
this is an editing page then maybe we
don't load the Styles something like
that let's see yeah let's keep working
on this for now because it's probably
going to take them a few minutes to get
the form give me access to the form that
they're working on to the test form so I
thought about maybe like just switching
over knowing that right now but I don't
think I don't think that'll work out
okay so in it for now let's see
a Jew
okay I was trying to check to make sure
that these different types weren't all
getting grouped together and they're not
so we can see there's your 26
that's interesting so this is definitely
out of order all right so we have
something for 2018 down below 2017 here
and then 2018
yes so the order is not even really
working the sorting is not working at
all
let me make sure I did save that and
we'll do a refresh actually ask you sir
did it work this time by 2017 15 15 18
18 18 18 18
20:18 one
six yeah I think it worked
nice okay cool so that works let's
switch this to make sure it works now
the aides newest all right now it's
switched over here great and now we
should be able to go in here
can we change state in here and have it
give us a rear ender I think we can sort
by let's switch it up yeah hey sorted to
newest mom back to oldest
whoops there we go oldest cool alright
that works so now on a state change we
have a change here awesome
okay cool let me check my time I still
good on time now the next thing that we
had was this alphabetical order and I
don't think that this will work as we're
doing it here but let's I don't know
let's just give it a shot
it'll only take a second and if it works
it'll save a lot of time
yeah that does not look like
alphabetical order yeah and definitely
not okay so that's not working so this
setup here does work what we need to do
though is get the the alphabetical order
working so we'll just need to change
what's here and what's here and then
we'll be all set with with the logic of
it the next step then would be to tie it
in to the UI so to make some sort of a
drop-down radio button something like
that and have that set the state for
sort by and then everything else will
work this I really don't like having all
this right here in the component but it
it does make things it uses less code
than our other solution really
yeah so I don't know maybe I'll leave it
like this let me know y'all think we'll
see we'll see how much gets added to
when we try to do alphabetical order
okay well let's go back to our
documentation and let's see so by
default we do have alphabetical order
when using sort
hmm
buffoon idiot the array
all right this is where we could
probably put in here greater than or
less than right let's try that out
wait a second nice we have a string
right here console
disorder any sort
and that's sort of a it looks like this
sorted this string in alphabetical order
but it used this which is what we're
currently using so this was string array
dot sort right or no did it not use
compare numbers there it didn't it just
you sort okay all right sorry I misread
that
okay so then yeah let's let's try the
greater than less then see what we get
right let me I'm gonna check the live
chat just for a second okay Evo says hey
those are going and ego says couldn't
you extract the date parsing code into
separate function which removes a few
lines of the current component yeah you
know what I've been thinking about that
I think that's a good idea I'm just not
I haven't really thought about how I'd
do it but you know if we're repeating
ourselves four times here there's got to
be a better way to do it so yeah I mean
right now it's it's not a huge deal
right it's only four times it doesn't
take up that much space but I'd still
rather be able to do it I'm afraid like
the solution to this would end up taking
up more lines than what we have now
really but it does make me want to you
know pull this out and have a different
function all right so I'm gonna try to
just add in a greater than sign and see
what happens
let's give it a refresh and see did I
change this up here officer let's change
it whoops let's change it up here
okay so right off the bat we'll have
that and
okay
it doesn't look like this is doing
anything let me make sure I'm title
rendered okay damn one by title let's
see what kind of change we have let's
just do it this way so we have these a
and B reversed so that's why I'm just
going with greater than both times and
let's see what I want to do is sort it
this way and then change state over here
and let's go alright so something
happened
it's not quite right it's haha so a
change is happening but it's not quite
alphabetical okay
Joey says in the sort docs there's an
example sort by name that may be
relevant okay cool let's check it out
oops my timer is up so maybe we'll have
to check that out
ah
maybe we should do something like this
then okay that'll probably be the next
thing that that I'll try what's this Eva
says playing game that was advocate
maybe but you could use lodash to do
this for you okay all right what what in
lodash then would help is there like a
sorting thing in low - that would help
us out with this I kind of think we're
pretty close I wish that if I was gonna
use low - I wish I would have known
about it last week uh-huh but add a to
lower case maybe yeah I guess we could I
could do to lower case I'm trying to
think if the titles yeah you know what
I'm not I'm sure that the titles are all
the same case okay well I have to yeah
I've got to answer questions now in the
live chat and this so if if you're kind
of wondering how we're gonna solve this
I made you stream it tomorrow but if I
don't and let's say I fix it before then
this is probably what I'm gonna use
something like this and this may be a
good candidate to just use a separate
function for since we really just care
about returning you know like one or
negative one okay
all right so let me go back let's um
let's commit this and then push it up to
github that way you all will have all
this code to check out as well
that is good good add we're gonna get
added we just gonna add everything just
with a period there and then we'll do
our yarn cm this is kind of a little
custom thing we have set up to help you
know walk someone through doing a nice
commit message so let's say that is a
new feature and this is gonna be a date
logic to search no I don't think so
all right let's see if we passed the
test
looks pretty good so far I think this is
gonna work yay and now all right all
this code is now on github and I will
scroll up a bit and try to answer all
the questions
okay kiss sure says NPM is not working
with with get for Windows I'm not sure I
mean I it's really hard for me to tell
what the problem is
you know without being able to see
what's going on you think I don't think
we need a specific version of node for
this project I'm not sure I mean I'd say
you know make sure node is up-to-date
and an NPM they're up to date you can
use yarn if you want and it's all yarn
and use that that's what we're using
let's see but I'm not sure I pronounce
the name is being har gh8 V so sorry I
don't know how to pronounce that let me
know the correct way to pronounce it and
I will do my best to say it correctly
but anyway they asked from where I
learned coding so you can learn coding
from free code camp so free code camp
dot work has a lot of challenges to walk
you through learning front-end
programming first and then you do all
the way through back end and so it's
it's somewhat comprehensive it's going
to be a lot of JavaScript so if you're
interested in JavaScript that would be
good otherwise there are some other
programs like Udacity has some good
courses on a variety of different things
so everything from you know web
development to self-driving cars they
have a lot of stuff and for that kind of
a beginner level code Academy has a lot
of good beginner tutorials so I'd say
those three places are a good place to
start
oh they also asked which programming
language is best for me I'm a complete
beginner yeah I I mean I started out
with JavaScript mostly I think it was a
good language to start with because you
don't need really anything special to
start out with it the browser you can
just start doing stuff in the console on
your browser but you know there's a good
argument to be made that other
programming languages are easy so
kishore says like for a beginner Python
and C is a start-up I thought is nice
because there's a lot less in terms of
syntax to have to remember at first so
that would be a good place to start it
does kind of depend on what you want to
do apology say I was trying to hold back
this yawn for a while now and I couldn't
do it any longer
yeah so I would say of of the three so
Kishore mentions HTML CSS and JavaScript
if you want to be a web developer so for
sure if you want to do web stuff for
sure start with that you're going to be
using you know JavaScript most of the
time as a web developer so especially if
you're doing more front-end stuff but
otherwise if you don't want to do ever
you're not sure what you want to do then
I I would say Python Kishore also
mentioned C C's a good place to get like
some really basic stuff and to
understand like a lot of concepts that
you don't even have to think about when
you do JavaScript and C like like the
type of variable that you're setting
Java you never have to really like think
beforehand all right what type is this
going to be right you don't have to say
like is this gonna be a 32-bit integer
or something like that right but in
other some other languages and C is like
this you really do have to put some
thought into things like that beforehand
so if you want to start a really basic
level that's a place to start I don't
know in terms of being able to get up
started quickly and build like cool
useful things quickly and be able to get
paid for it
I wouldn't start with C message my
opinion I don't have that much
experience with C so it may be wrong
I think HTML CSS JavaScript would be the
way to go to be able to start building
real things quickly there's a huge
market for that so it really depends a
lot on what you're trying to do Dimitri
says I want to be a cyber sportsman and
play CS 1.6 I wanted to be a
professional Starcraft player when I was
in high school I wanted to move to South
Korea and be approached arc a flare
didn't happen
okay gander seven says I would say start
with Java or C sharp they strongly typed
similar to a lot of languages and will
catch a lot of errors before you run it
yeah that so I didn't think of it that
way but being strongly typed might be
helpful because there's less room for
errors when you're using a strongly
typed language as opposed to JavaScript
which is what do we say loosely type
could that be the opposite of strongly
typed
weakly typed yeah I hadn't thought of
that but that's that's another option
I'm sorry I feel like we're not giving
you a great answer we're just giving you
like every language as an answer but
really it it really does depend so much
on what you're looking to do and what
your situation is okay also says what
laptop is best Kishore says Mac is good
for web dev yeah I do see that a lot of
web developers using Mac's especially
the MacBook Pro seems to be a very
popular one it has enough power to do
pretty much whatever you want as a web
developer I use a MacBook Pro when I'm
not in my office so I would go with a
Mac but there are people that run Linux
machines people who do Windows it really
doesn't matter as long as that
particular laptop has you know a good
screen if you're gonna be looking at the
screen all day you want to have a nice
screen and you want to be able to run
which you need to run so it needs to
have enough power to be able to you know
have a bunch of tabs open in Chrome and
to be able to have your code editor open
and you know running some things locally
then you need that so it doesn't need to
be really expensive
the hell aside Wow I'm just kidding so
drowsy maybe I'm not all the way
recovered yet
my energy has just dropped
oh here's a good piece of information so
Evo is shared that says when you're
doing the sorting stuff always do to
uppercase and not to lower case because
the care there's a character in German
that gets translated when to SS in
uppercase so I guess yeah okay yeah so I
don't know that much about German so but
to uppercase is the better way to go
a Pedro asks would you say the market is
saturated web developers bringing down
the overall wage I I think it there are
like levels of the market so there are a
lot of web developers at a kind of a low
level range that are willing to take
work for next to nothing especially on
freelance sites but if you kind of get
past that and you get up into a level
where you're getting into like doing
work for bigger companies you know more
more expensive work when you get up into
that level I don't think it's
oversaturated because there's a I
suppose like there's a big difference
between somebody who can only do minor
things and maybe they're doing that work
now I'm not saying everybody that's
doing the really cheap work is not
capable of doing more expensive work
because that's certainly not the case
there probably a lot of people that are
really good that for whatever reason are
just at that level right now but if you
can break through that and get to some
more higher paying clients then you get
into a level of being able to do things
that maybe the the majority you know
can't do and so when you think of like
qualified developers I don't think
there's a saturation this is just my
observation from what I've seen in just
around the internet looking at resumes
looking at job descriptions and being a
freelancer for a few years myself I I
think yeah so it's basically super
saturated down here at the bottom at the
low salary level you know and just
bidding on jobs that are paying nothing
and then once you get past that then
there's there's not as much saturation
there's a lot of jobs out there I see
really
tempting job offers nearly every day
that I'm entirely qualified for and I I
mean you all see me I'm not like some
spectacular rock star developer right
I'm just I mean average right like
average would be a compliment for me
right I'm not you know and there's still
so many really good jobs that that I'm
qualified more for just with my current
skillset of the stuff that we've been
doing on on this stream so anyway that's
my take on it and that's from being in
the United States as well it may be
different in different areas of the
world but hang in there if you're kind
of just trying to make some money at
this level I was there for a while and
it's tough to break through and get more
especially if you're freelance it's
really tough to break through and get
higher paying clients that really know
what quality work is and willing to pay
for it so just keep working at it you
know try to make as many connections as
you can and you know maybe try to get a
job with an agency or something so that
you can you'll get access to those
higher paying clients alright just a few
more questions and then I'll have to
finish up
I would love to know what you all think
about market saturation and things that
like that that I was just talking about
because I only have a really specific
perspective from from where I am but you
know you all from all over the place so
I'm sure you could weigh in and you know
what things are like in your area with
the type of work that you're doing
Sathya says I want to develop my own
apps I'm starting to code nowadays
though so how should I proceed I wanted
to make a social network app from my
college project if you have experience
with JavaScript and you want to do apps
and also especially if you have any
experience with react I would use react
native to make apps there's no need for
you to learn any anything else so that
would be the fastest way and you can
make good quality apps like that if
you're not that familiar with it and you
know some Java then go that route with
with Android or if you know what is it
Swift with iOS or the new stuff is
Kotlin if you if you don't know any
JavaScript or Android or Swift you try
learning Kotlin because that's like the
new cool thing that that everybody's
doing for Android development so that
those would be my suggestions we have
done some some app work with react
native on the stream
not a whole lot we've done some Evo says
this is in regard to the question we had
earlier about market saturation bringing
down wages so Evo says in my opinion if
you know how to sell yourself you can
get a nice paycheck you just need to
make yourself stand out which is easier
said than done yeah yeah that mean that
that is definitely the case especially
when you're trying to break through from
that lower level there's a ton of people
out there offering you know seemingly
all the same stuff and for really cheap
so you do have
for certain clientele you need to make
the case for why you're different or
better or worth more some clients will
never understand that and you don't know
you don't want those clients if you have
to take them to pay the bills take them
but you really want to get to a level of
client that understands that quality
takes money so you know be if you can be
more specific like more particular about
what jobs you take then do and you'll be
a lot happier going with clients that
understand that but I totally understand
if you got to pay the bills I was there
and I had to take projects that I didn't
want to work on clients that I knew
we're gonna be trouble
majority my clients were excellent but
occasionally you know you do you know
you get a bad feeling about a client
base so some of the stuff they're saying
and you got to make that decision like
how bad do I really need this money and
sometimes you need the money so you got
to take it
michael says my plan is to do supercut
of every time Jesse yawns and these
dreams
I mean yawning so much the past couple
of weeks I don't know what's wrong with
me
Chris that says are there less foul
permission issues with Ubuntu than Mac
OS I don't know personally I haven't
used the blue two as an nos like on a
laptop or desktop or anything like that
I've only used it as a server so not
really sure Jolie says I think there's
similar or the same they're both UNIX
based Anthony says contracting versus
permanent I enjoy working permanently
right now I did a lot of freelance stuff
which it's not exactly a contract thing
I guess but it's nice to be able to
count on a steady paycheck be little
plan ahead you know like here's what I'm
gonna be doing a year from now when
you're freelance it's just it's not as
easy so you do get to work on a variety
of projects and meet new people so it
can be exciting but you just give up
some of that stability so it just kind
of depends on where you're at in life
and and what you need in terms of you
know pay stability and things like that
with a family you know for kids and wife
stability especially financial stability
being able to have health insurance
those are really important you know to
my wife and I so you know I that's why
I'm not freelancing anymore Michael says
I'm just I'm just looking for a job I
can do while I'm out on disability Oh
Michael I know you're out on disability
I hope everything gets better for you
you know healed up
let's see Nina asked what state manager
do you use Redux or flux I've used Redux
before so if I had to choose I'm like
I'm using Redux but if I need to we're
not using Redux on this project Evo says
in the Netherlands the market situation
is not that bad there are loads of job
opportunities here heard on the news
that they need around 200,000 developers
and IT staff Wow nice yeah I mean I I do
you always hear that that the job
outlook for developers and in really all
programming jobs it seems like just
keeps on you know increasing it it looks
good there's a good outlook so for the
foreseeable future it's definitely a a
good place to be if you get a job
Michael says I know what I can do but I
don't know how to sell it yeah I never
like the selling part of it sometimes if
you can find someone that will partner
with you and they can sell and they get
a percentage of the money then that's
not a bad a bad deal you can just do the
code and they can find new clients
sometimes like when I would get clients
especially if they were in a market that
I wanted to get into I would offer deals
like I'd say if you bring me in a client
and they sign a contract like then
you'll get like either money or you'll
get free work for me and you know you
can kind of incentivize people to try to
do networking for you and try to break
get clients for you so that can be
useful as well
okay Joey says and this is talking about
apps says progressive web apps are great
on Android and create react app
practically does all the work definitely
true yeah so if you don't need like an
app that's going to be on the App Store
you just need something that runs well
on a phone you can definitely do a
progressive web app with create react
app that's I mean we haven't really been
highlighting it that much but a lot of
the stuff that we've built over the last
few months have been progressive web
apps and they do work well on Android
like as a progressive web app
Oh ambition so speaking of jobs how did
your interview job interview go yeah
whoa so yeah I haven't given an update
on that sorry so the job interview went
well so I'm gonna give you a quick
breakdown of what happened so interview
went really well I did get offered the
job and it wasn't as much as I had hoped
for did a little negotiation got it up a
bit higher but it wasn't it didn't make
sense for me to leave my current
position based on a lot of different
factors so I tried to quantify as many
factors as I could so some meaning like
put a dollar value on all the factors
and then add that up to try to compare
so after I did all that that's when I
realized you know hey this this offer is
not quite good enough for me to justify
leaving where I'm at right now so that's
where it's at I really the company was a
great company it would have been a lot
of fun to work there it seems like yeah
but it just wasn't it wasn't quite
enough for me to want to leave so that's
how it went it was a great process I'm
glad I went through it it was really
nice meeting you know developers from a
different company and I really enjoyed
the interview process even the
whiteboard problem was fun it was it was
cool it's a nice feeling when somebody
like recognizes your abilities and wants
you to you know to work with them so
yeah so it was a good process I yeah I
I'm glad yeah I'm letting it happen
but I'll be staying here which is good
news for the stream because nothing will
change with the stream we'll still be
able to do it during you know during the
day so I'm happy about that and that was
one of the things that I did factor in
is the ability to be able to keep doing
the stream you know that was important
to me that's one of those things that's
really really hard to put a dollar value
on
nobody that was definitely a factor
okay Anthony says thanks Jessie I have a
little one too here in the UK
contracting seems to pay really well
compared okay cool
yeah that's that's good to know
it is cool to know like in different
parts of the world what the because
every market is kind of different you
know
Joey says have you seen the new react
context API it looks like it could
replace Redux in most cases I haven't
seen that much on it other than some
tweets about it I haven't I just haven't
taken the time to really look into it
more so I'm I'm definitely interested
you know especially I don't want to keep
thinking in terms of redux for you know
upcoming projects if it's going to be
unnecessary so I definitely want to
check that out more and maybe after I
learn more about it we can you know talk
about it more on the stream and maybe
maybe start using it demo some of it at
some point not not right now not on this
project most likely signee says is there
a playlist of your various streams and
basic installation required to start and
follow your course okay so on so I have
my own YouTube channel so this is the
free code camp channel but if you check
in the description there should be a
link to my channel I have a video I
think it's the the latest video on that
channel has like a purple background and
it's it's something like git and it's
talking about like using it and github
and and cloning things from get up check
out that video that will give you a good
introduction it starts out really basics
you might might not need to watch it all
but I'll give you a good introduction on
how to get things started for most of
these projects also if you look at the
project repositories on github
we usually have instructions in the
readme for how to start everything and
then we have a contributing MD file that
gives you instructions on how to
contribute so I'd start with that and
I'm hoping to do some more videos to
kind of go more in depth on how to start
these projects and help with them so
hopefully I can get those videos made
soon and if you need any more help let
me know if it's for a particular project
you know you could just open up an issue
in that particular repository or let me
know however on social media on the
stream whatever is best for you and and
then I can give you more specific help
you know based on what you're trying to
do let's see
Lorena says what does they recommend mid
level of education or path to follow it
really really depends on what you want
to do since I'm in web development I'll
give you kind of what what I would do to
be a web developer and it depends on
what you know so I'm going to assume
like totally beginner level if if you
already know that then you can just kind
of skip some of these steps but totally
beginner level I would start out with
some basic stuff so free code camp dot
org has like challenges that'll sort you
out at a really low level you could work
your way up as you're doing free code
camp if you find another tutorial
somewhere that you can learn more about
a particular thing like no problem you
can branch out and follow that and then
come back that's how I did it if you if
you don't particularly like that style
of learning there are other styles so
Udacity courses is more video based so I
think it's udacity.com
they of courses some are paid courses
some are free courses they have a lot of
free courses that are helpful for web
development they're more video based so
if you're into more video learning you
can do that or watch YouTube videos of
on free code camp if you like to just
read like a book check out the book
called you don't know Jas it's available
for free to read on your computer on
github so you can buy the actual book if
you want or you can read it for free
online but that would be a nice
introduction to JavaScript just being
able to read it all out so if you want
to be a web developer though you know
HTML CSS and then JavaScript or luego
and usually in that order because HTML
be the easiest CSS shouldn't be your
that difficult to learn enough to do
some cool stuff with and then Java
scripts going to be the thing
that you just keep on learning and
learning and you kind of you never get
finished learning it but it will allow
you to do the most stuff and to get jobs
that can make you the most money and you
can do kind of the you can make more
powerful things and cooler things with
it so that's kind of I know that kind of
a big overview hopefully that helps
somewhat it's let me check the time all
right I think I can finish this up Joey
says the new context API seems pretty
simple it can be understood in a matter
of minutes it's just an alpha though so
not ready for production yet okay yeah I
I didn't think it was quite ready yet so
yeah so maybe a while before we demo it
but I'm really glad to know that it's
it's simple Anthony asks what I used to
stream with OBS so OBS is free software
to help you stream so I just have that
set up and then you know of course also
YouTube alright I've gotten to the
bottom hopefully I didn't miss anyone's
questions I did skip over a few
statements in there and that was just
for time to apologize if I didn't read
everything out all right cool
so I have less than 10 minutes now thank
you all for watching and for being so
helpful when we were trying to go
through this problem this seems like
it's taking such a long time so thanks
for your patience but I think we're
really really close to having everything
working with the sorting the way we want
let me think anything else I only have
anything else right now I will try to
stream tomorrow around my normal time so
around 12 noon if I can I'll let you
know via Twitter if you want to follow
me on Twitter also Instagram so you can
check that out if you interested in any
my videos you know check out my YouTube
channel links in the description and
yeah that's it for me so until tomorrow
have a wonderful day